مشاهدينا مرحبا بكم في قناه الجزيره قال
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه ان رئيس الروسي
دمر ثلث البنيه الاساسيه في اوكرانيا
واضاف ان حلف شمال الاطلسي عازم على تقديم
الدعم لاوكرانيا مهما تطلب الامر والهذا
الدعم يشمل ومساعدات عسكريه واقتصاديه
وانسانيه
قدمت رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه
لتمويل اعاده اعمار اوكرانيا ايضا مقترحا
لانشاء محكمه خاصه مدعومه امنيا لمحاسبه
روسيا في المقابله قال مدير ومنع الانتشار
والسيطره على الاسلحه في الخارجيه الروسيه
ان الغربه يستخدم امكانيات البنيه التحتيه
الفضائيه المدنيه لدعم العمليات
الاوكرانيه وحضر من ان الاقمار الصناعيه
شبه المدنيه المستخدمه في اوكرانيا يمكن
ان تصبح هدفا مشروعا للقوات الروسيه
كما قالت الخارجيه الروسيه تتخذ ما وصفتها
باجراءات مناسبه اذا تعلق الامر بمصادره
اصولها في الاتحاد الاوروبي
اكد مصدر رسمي تركي للجزيره اكتمال
التحضيرات لعمليه عسكريه بريه تركيه
شماليه سوريا وقال ان العمليه لن تهدد
القوات الامريكيه والروسيه واكد رفض انقره
الانتشار الشكلي لقوات النظام السوري في
مناطق ما تعرف بقوته سوريا الديمقراطيه
قال البنت تقول ان وزير الدفاع لايت اوستن
اعرب في اتصال الهاتفين مع نظيره التركي
خلوصي اكار عن معارضه البنتاجون الشديده
لعمليه عسكريه تركيه في سوريا وكان متحدث
باسم البنتاجون باتريك رايدر
اكد انه واشطن تقر بما خوف تركيا الامنيا
المشروعه بشان الاعمال الارهابيه على
اراضيها وحذر في الوقت نفسه من ان اجتياح
بريا تركيا في تلك المنطقه سيهدد ما انجز
في محاربه تنظيم الدوله
نفت بجين سعيه هذه خوذي سباق تسلح النووي
واكدت التزامها بعدم البدء باستخدام
الاسلحه النوويه وباحتفاظها بالحد الادنى
المطلوب لقواتها النوويه ضمن سياستها
للامن القومي
نقلت وكاله التاسعه وزير الخارجيه الروسيه
السير الى بروفا قوله انه من الضروريه
لتجنب اي مواجهه عسكريه بين القوه النوويه
كما اكدت المتحدثه باسميه وزاره الخارجيه
الروسيه ماريا زخرفه ان روسيا لا تعتزم
مناقشه معاهده ستارت الجديده مع الولايات
المتحده بينما تزود واشتياز بالاسلحه
انتهى الموجز شيكولاته
[موسيقى]